Oh
Mickey Mouse in the three musketeers
that is pretty much exactly what you get
Mickey Donald and Goofy all going off to
save princess Minnie so that evil
captain Pete can't take over the crown
yes somehow connecting her makes him
king is there's a really story base
the plot is I know that was religious
yeah about a generic an old-fashioned a
cartoon plot for kid goes so is it any
good I have to pick on something that
obviously meant for like little little
kids I mean it's a Mickey Mouse
direct-to-dvd movie what do you expect
but again I guess it's not fair Mickey's
had some really good stuff there was a
great short he was in called The Prince
and the pauper Fantasia is a masterpiece
even that Mickey's what's fun Christmas
had a lot of charm to it they don't
really describe as having a lot of charm
but it's a harmless every character and
motivation is exactly what you think
it's going to be Mickey is optimistic
but he dreams of being a Mouseketeer
Sarah would just say that you know what
I mean goofy is a doofus but he wants to
apply his brain Donald is a coward and
wants to learn how to be brave and many
as the princess of course you want to
fall in love there is nothing new or
original in this even though songs are
classical public-domain tunes that they
just put lyrics to some of them already
have lyrics they just add new one and it
guess it's good this teaches kids
classical music but this music you're
going to hear everywhere anyway I don't
know the animation is clearly trying and
the backgrounds are clearly trying but
nothing really stands out is great
everybody does exactly what you think
they do everybody reacts exactly how you
think they react so why doesn't this
work as well as say the Buzz Lightyear
cartoon well that one's still through in
some good laughs and it was creative it
had kind of a goofy story but it also
has some imagination to it the best way
I can describe this one is by looking at
the opening and closing credits you see
this comic strip style this was very
popular back in the day in fact these
Mickey Mouse comics are kind of these
rarities they're seen as this pure
innocent artwork of Morrison
time they didn't have much depth in fact
they had virtually no them thought they
were so simple and colorful that kids
really loved it and it's our carried
over for some adults this is pretty much
the same thing it's innocent it's
harmless but I don't really see any
reason to watch it either it's fun for
kids I guess but aside from the
smoothness of the animation and some of
the backgrounds
nothing really screams Disney top of the
game
but again it's a directed DVD Mickey
Mouse movie but again more effort has
been put into those in the past but
again it's not like no leper would put
into this but priming is more
complicated than these two be if you're
an adult isn't likely you'll get into it
well if you're a little little kid that
just wants to see Mickey Mouse go on an
adventure
it's energized colorful and harmless
don't expect anything great but honestly
you probably weren't anyway you're
probably just expecting a Mickey Mouse
cartoon and that's what you get a really
long Mickey Mouse cartoon find four
little boys and girls but that's really
about it
it's all for one and one for
[Music]
you